so we've got the function G here what I
want you to do is pause the video and
figure out what G of 1 is figure out
what G of 2 is G of 3 and G of 4 figure
out what all four of these are alright
now let's work through this together so
G of 1 if n is equal to 1 well then
we're going to hit this case right over
here if n is equal to 1 G is equal to 4
so that was pretty straightforward now G
of 2 G of 2 if n is equal to 2
well that's n is 2 is greater than 1 and
it's a whole number and so we would use
this case so this is interesting because
it's defined in terms of the function
but it's not defined in terms of G of n
but G of n minus 1 so if n is 2 because
we're evaluating G of 2 here this is
going to be G of 2 minus 1 or G of 1
plus 3.2 plus 3.2 well what's that going
to be well G of 1 we know is equal to 4
we just figured that out so 4 plus 3
point 2 that is 7 point 2 all right
let's keep going G of 3 we're going to
fall into this case again because 3 is
greater than 1 and it's a whole number
so this is going to be G of 3 minus 1 or
G of 2 plus 3 point 2 plus 3 point 2
well we know what G of 2 is it's 7 point
2 we just figure that out it is seven
point two seven point two plus three
point two is going to be equal to 10
point four and then G of 4 well we fall
here again this is going to be G of
three plus three point two G of 3 plus
three point two what is that going to be
equal to well G of three we just figured
out is ten point four ten point four
plus three point two is going to be
thirteen point six and so what you have
here this is actually quite interesting
you can think of this this function and
dysfunction Jean you see that it's
defined over all positive integers
because it's defined over positive
integers we could think of it as
defining a sequence and we see what the
sequence here is the first term
first term is for second term is 7.2
next term is 10.4 next term is 13.6 and
it could keep going on and on and on and
what's happening what's happening in the
sequence well we're starting with four
we're starting with four and that's this
case of the function gave us that if n
is equal to four is your if n is n is
equal to 1 the function is going to be
equal to 4 and then for each term after
that you take the previous term and you
add 3.2 so we add 3.2 for the second
term we add 3.2 so we just keep adding
we just keep adding three point three
point two nine point three two three
point two to get to the next term now we
could have defined it that way because
hey let's have a sequence for the first
term is four then we keep adding three
point two to get each next term but this
is another interesting way to find it
defining it in this way of defining it
where we defined it as an algebraic
function a function that's defined over
all positive integers where we have a
base case and the base case really in
this case gave us our first term and
then we have this other case that's
defined in terms of the function then
you have to recurse backwards to
eventually get to a base case we call
this a recursive function a recursive
recursive function so with this example
we're seeing how a recursive function
can be used to define an actual sequence
and you know you could we went in order
here but you could have gone the other
way around if I said oh well what's a
what's G of what's G of six well you go
into this case you would say okay that's
going to be G of 5 plus 3.2 it's going
to be the previous term plus 3 point
plus 3.2 if we view it if we view it as
a sequence well then we're going to
figure out what the previous term is G
of 5 is going to be G of 4 G of 4 plus
3.2 and you would keep going back and
back and back but we've already figured
out what G of 4 is it's thirteen point
six thirteen point six so this is 16.8
and then if G of 5 is 16
twenty-eight 16.8 yet 3.2 there you
would get 20 so you could start at go6
and keep backing up all the way until
you get to G of one and then you figure
out what that is you get you could
recurse back to your base case and then
you're able to to fill in all the blanks
so let's do a few more examples of this
so we have this function here so let's
say that this defines a sequence let's
think about what the first four terms of
that sequence are and once again I
encourage you to pause the video and
figure that out alright let's work
through it so H of one is well they very
clearly tell us that's going to be 14 if
n is equal to 1 H is 14 H of 2 H of 2
well now we're falling into this case
because 2 is greater than 1 and it's a
whole number so it's going to be 28 over
H of 1 over H of 1 well we know H of 1
is 14 so it's going to be 28 over 14
which is equal to 2 now H of 3 H of 3
we're going to fall into this case again
it's going to be 28 28 divided by H of 2
for thinking of this as a sequence
divided by the previous term in the
sequence so 28 divided by H of 2 we know
that H of 2 is equal to is equal to 2 we
just figure that out so we go back to 14
something very interesting I think you
see where this is going H of 4 is going
to be 28 divided by H of 3 28 divided by
H of 3 which is 28 divided by this is H
of 3 right over here we just figured
that out divided by 14 which is back to
2 if we were to if we were to think of
this as a sequence we'd say all right
let's see we the first term is 14 then
we get 2 then we get to 2 then we go to
14 then we get to 2 so one way to think
about this sequence is that we just keep
alternating between 14 and twos all of
the odd terms of the sequence are 14 all
of the even terms of the sequence or two
that's one way to think about it or
another way to think about it is we're
starting with 14 and each successive
term is the pre
is term divided is 28 divided by the
previous term so here 28 divided by 14
is 2 28 divided by 2 is 14 28 divided by
14 is 2 and we keep going on and on and
on and that's what was actually going on
right over there let's do one more of
these and this one is interesting
because we now have we now have 2 we now
have two base cases so let's think about
this this is and actually let's just
let's just say we wanted to figure out
we wanted to figure out what what f of 4
is f of 4 well we're going to fall into
this case 4 is greater than 2 and it's a
whole number it's going to be F of 4
minus 2 so it's going to be F of 2 plus
F of 4 minus 1 plus F of 3 so F of 4 is
going to be the sum of the preceding two
numbers all right so let's figure out
what F of 3 is going to be F of 3 we
fall into this case again it's going to
be F of 3 minus 2 is F of 1 plus F of 3
minus 1 plus F of 2 the sum of the
preceding two numbers so let's figure
out what F of 2 is going to be well now
we're not doing the sum of the preceding
two numbers anymore we fall into this
base case n is now equal to 2 it's going
to be equal to negative 4 and we're
going to figure out what F of 1 is as
well and we see when N is equal to 1 F
is equal to negative 6 we have two base
cases right over here base base cases
cases that aren't defined in terms of
the function itself and you need that
because otherwise you just be recursing
forever you would never get to actual
numbers but now we can use these to fill
in the values up here so the sequence is
negative 6 then we go to negative 4 as
the second term and then the third term
is the sum of the previous two negative
4 plus the negative 6 plus negative 4 is
negative 10 negative 6 plus negative 4
is negative 10 and then the fourth term
is the sum of the previous two we see it
right over here the second term F of 2
plus F of 3 negative 4 plus negative 10
is negative 14 and we could keep going
on and on and on like that so
so right over here is negative 14 so the
whole point of this video you're a
little bit familiar with recursive
functions now and also you can see how
these can be used to define actual
sequences